if you want to make the audience see
something that's just not there you've
got to go talk to the visual effects
artists agreed they truly are the unsung
heroes of film fashioning miracles with
envy able ease here are the nominees for
achievement in visual effects gravity
Tim Weber
Chris Lawrence David sharp and Neil
corbelled the hobbit the desolation of
smaug Joel Atari Eric Stainton David
Clayton and Eric Reynolds iron man 3
Christopher Townsend Guy Williams Eric
Nash and Dan sudoc the Lone Ranger Tim
Alexander Gary broznich Anson Williams
and Joe Frazier star trek into darkness
Roger diet Patrick - buck ban Grossman
and Burt Dalton the Oscar goes to
mmm gravity sim well this law David sure
and milk
on behalf of all of us thank you so much
to the Academy for this honor in a year
with such amazing visual effects visual
effects and filmmaking is is all about
the team and there's far too many to
thank properly but I'd like to mention
David Heyman Nikki penny Emmanuel
Lubezki all of the shooting crew RSP and
the incredible team of Framestore it
seemed like a crazy project so thank you
to Warner Brothers and in particular
kristef arya for believing in it to
George Clooney and especially Sandra
Bullock for filling our visual effects
with with life and with emotion but most
of all to Alfonso Cuaron for having with
her Nass the the vision of this of this
breathtaking film the audacity to make
it happen and the courage to trust us to
have such a big part in in making it
come to life and finally thank you to
our families and the families of all
visual effects artists thank you very
much